russia's Foreign Minister has joined
almost 8,000 parliamentarians and
political experts from more than 100
states at Moscow's International Forum
on the development of parliamentarianism
Nikolas Cobb the chair of Britain's
Westminister Russia forum was there and
joins us now live in the studio
you're very welcome now how do you
assess the results of the forum I was
very positive I mean there 132
delegations around about 500 attendees
it was a good free and frank discussion
and debate sometimes quite heated
sometimes quite fiery but very positive
in it was really promoting just
cooperation between Parliament's it was
good to see the whole range of delegates
there from Africa and from Asia and from
you know from the UK and elsewhere so
ISM it was a good mix of people very
enjoyable fiery debate is of course
likely to be expected there but it was a
good thing what do you make of current
relations between the UK and Russia well
if you look at I think that this it's a
binary question if you look at it from
the political side absolutely we're all
aware of the political difficulties
between our two countries and we're not
even ready to explain them about this in
detail but the route is I think the the
relations go further than just the
politics if you look at business you
have agriculture in fact the business
relations are improving you look at
culture culture hasn't been impacted you
can't walk down the streets of London
without hearing Russian spoken so
actually there are many positive sighs
the relationship the very functional
sites the relationships so I think it's
a binary point and I have to agree with
you there I think that when it comes to
the people that's one of the most
important things here and just like
you're saying in London you're gonna
hear Russian speaking here in Moscow
walking down the street being an expat
myself here you're hearing English all
the time now you and members of your
organization have been granted leading
civil awards by the Russian government
for your contribution to strengthening
those relations between the two
countries do such initiatives help boost
cooperation they do know we were awarded
though we were some awards were were
made and people very happy with them and
it's it's really in line with a long
line of
after many years of cooperation now
these worse high civic awards from the
National Civic Council and also from the
National Forum for social social
recognition so these are high civic
awards very positive and it really did
help people I think it just helped gay
people with a boost actually and we're
talking about people who were artists
no misses people with not a number of
years of hard work so it was a great
pleasure to award them medal if we stick
with relations of course everybody's
looking forward to who's going to be
taking over as prime minister in the UK
so that's obviously going to affect how
things move forward between the two
countries who do you think will win that
Tory leadership race I think the current
current state a tweet Boris Johnson I
mean he's leading I've been away from
from the UK for a week now and I haven't
really been following news but when I
left he was certainly quite a long way
ahead then Jeremy Hunt so I think he
will be
I think he'll I think he'll clinch it
well he's definitely being looked at as
the favorite who do you think between
the two of them would be more of a
breath of fresh air when it comes to UK
Russia relations it's hard to tell I
think Boris Johnson would be the via
they're the same amazing candidate I
think he would possibly be the more
practical of the two and they're
certainly relations needs to be improved
but they won't really happen till after
the BRICS the question is is is resolved
the UK is going through a whole period
of change in terms of brexit so until
that is actually resolved one way or the
other and we know what direction the UK
is going then I think UK Russia
relations will come back with Russia and
UK have a lot that we can do post brexit
particularly the trade if we take a
wider look at Europe as a whole Putin
was yesterday just in Italy the two were
talking about the ties between the two
countries Russia has also just been
readmitted readmitted to the Council of
Europe are these sort of things an
indicator that ties with Europe
generally and hence with the UK in
particular are on the mend I think they
are to a point everything to a point I
think they are you know the dialogue is
important and a readmission back to
paces is is a positive step as its
as really dialog I mean and that's this
point of dialogue you can disagree with
with the poor that by the content of the
discussion but you still need to have
that comment that discussion so it's
important that Russia has been
readmitted and absolutely I think the
relationships are becoming more
functional you know becoming very
practical there are certain topics to
the realpolitik now and the countries
still need to need to move forward as
chair of the Westminster Russia forum
what sort of activities did you engage
in whilst here in Russia
well I attended the forum in the early
to mid part of the week we've since
engaged with some battle bilateral
relations with members of the State Duma
and others also we we met today with
mokemo the Foreign Affairs University
and a host of others and really
discussing concrete actions in terms of
bilateral relations conferences and
events aimed solely to help improve
relations both here and in Russia so
it's been a very busy week a whole bunch
of meetings and it's been very enjoyable
very whirlwind getting here and doing so
much in so little time do you think that
the UK has any interest in some of
Russia's projects in Europe particularly
in the energy sphere I think they do I
mean if you look safe safer incite take
for example BP BP is still active in
exploration and production in Russia and
in fact the the chairman of BP I believe
met mr. Putin very recently is part of a
delegation of British businesses so yes
it's very positive and equally four are
safe from oil services right through to
renewable energies there are lots that
we can do together you know Britain's
has a lot of great offshore expertise
that particularly comes to Wallen gas
and that a good transferable cooperation
you